[BLANK_AUDIO]
This course, software architecture and design, is divided into parts,
each interleaving content lessons within class exercises.
After a few introductory lessons we will begin by looking at
the process of analyzing a design problem and specifying it using UML and
OCL. Both the static and dynamic aspects of analysis will be presented.
The next part of the course has to do with software architecture.
This includes different ways of thinking about and representing architectures,
the role of non functional requirements in determining architecture, and how
architectural designs can be refined into modules that can then be implemented.
The final part of the course gets into the specifics of software design,
including object design, design patterns, design principles, and design reviews.